am I doing three
too all right welcome back it is that
time of year again where everyone is
throwing football parties so we are
teaming up with holy guacamole to bring
you a winning combo it is a new
walki pizza Trend now apparently this is
all the rage on social anybody want to
try that right now well we have
something in store for you because we
always ready holy guacamole dip comes in
chunky spicy or classic and it's made
from 100% hand scoop H avocados it's
perfect for celebrating and we're going
to try the trend that everybody is doing
online and we're not going to do it
alone okay Nikki and Anthony from our
audience have
volunteered we're all going to do it
together and I want to try with spicy
classic and chunky what are you going to
go for yeah Anthony what are you picking
I think I'm going to do the classic and
Nikki oh I'm totally doing the chunky
I'm going spicy I went spicy too here
you go you want to like this or you want
to just dip um just yeah perfect okay
ready everyone ready have you
experienced this before this will be a
first all right all right here we go
everybody here we go
here there's nothing wrong about whoa
that is spicy I got a kiss I have a new
favorite guacamole it's the spicy it's
got such beautiful kick Nikki Anthony
what do you think what what are the
results I think the chunky guacamole on
Pizza is actually really good and I
can't wait to eat this again I'm
actually going to go for it Anthony
thoughts now I think the classic is
delicious on the pizza my three-year-old
daughter my wife I think this is going
to be the new pizza night I feel bad
we're eating in front of everybody I
know but guess what everybody in our
audience is going home with $100 worth
of holy guacamole coupons so you can
gufy your pizza as well and at home you
can head to guaca pizza.com to learn how
you could get free holy guaca moly
products for a whole year I
spicy thank you everybody we make this
show for you so just you know eat a
little dip a little watch a little feel
a little and um just take it with you
cuz it's all for you thank you so much